c
bonsoir à tous
donc je me prénomme marion et eefje je
suis anthropologue de formation
photographes professionnels et chefs
d'entreprise revit et je viens vous
parler en fait d'un sujet qui nous
concerne tous les vacances pour
commencer j'ai une petite devinette pour
vous à votre avis là avec mon sourire ma
balise je pars en vacances où je rentre
de vacances
eh bien écoutez vous aurez la réponse
tout à l'heure je suis photographe donc
ça fait dix ans dans le milieu du
tourisme et du nautisme donc vous me
voyez la talonner habillés mais en fait
pendant dix ans j'étais pieds nus à bord
de bateaux voiliers a photographié des
gens vacances ans le beau métier et
pendant ces dix ans à observer les
vacanciers ayant moi même il a
l'occasion de partir en vacances et
apprécié mes vacances ya une question
que je me suis posée et que j'aimerais
partager justement aujourd'hui avec vous
la question c'est à quoi ça sert les
vacances
alors la photographe va vous répondre
que les vacances c'est le rêve et
vacanciers qui viennent en martinique il
va l'être sur la carte postale ils
veulent de belles photos montré que is y
était il profite du soleil de la bonne
nourriture passent du bon moment ils
veulent ramener des belles choses dans
leurs valises
donc les vacances et ce rêve
d'ailleurs on économise pour se payer
des vacances on arrive à la fin de
l'année d'ailleurs je j'ai une question
à vous poser
qui parmi vous est parti en vacances
cette année
eh bien les vacances c'est du luxe
maintenant c'est du luxe va ça fait
rêver
on travaille pour se payer ses vacances
là et d'ailleurs j'ai eu l'occasion de
parler avec certaines personnes qui
n'avaient pas eu la chance de partir en
vacances comme vous comme moi d'ailleurs
cette année et leur grand rêve c'est la
croisière voyez pendant une semaine on
part on est comme des rois
on mange à volonté on a des spectacles à
volonté on ramène énormément de choses
des photos et au delà de cette carte
postale
lassé l'anthropologue qui parle qu'on
s'intéresse aux vacanciers à celui qui a
fait huit heures d'avion pour venir
découvrir la martinique et inversement
le maintenaient qui prend l'avion pour
aller découvrir d'autres pays
il a laissé quelque chose en partant et
j'ai le souvenir de certains touristes
notamment une une femme d'une trentaine
d'années qui était parti en vacances en
martinique et qui me disait qu'elle
avait une collègue de travail infernales
mais imaginez un petit peu le genre de
collègues elle voulait pas aller au
travail
on peut avoir cette personne là et donc
en eau hasard de cette discussion je me
suis rendu compte que les vacances
étaient pour elle l'occasion de partir
de ce climat de travail qui lui plaisait
pas de l'entourage de travail qu'il
usait plaisait pas une fois il ya des
vacanciers qui viennent au chômage moi
je suis j'ai pas de boulot mais ils ont
pu se payer le billet n'ont pas de
boulot je me souviens aussi d'un couple
en voyage de noces alors voyez voyage de
noces c'est le rêve
un couple de jeunes donc avait été gâté
pour leur mariage et qui avait eu un
beau chèque bien gâtés dans l' enveloppe
et qui avait eu donc leur voyage de
noces en martinique et le jeune marié
m'avait confié qu' il voulait pas
reprendre l'avion dans deux jours il
comptait les jours voire les heures
passent qu'entre autres qui avaient le
crédit de la maison en rentrant à payer
et pas mal d'autres choses à assumer et
je vous passe aussi en tant que
photographe on apprend observé avant de
photographier et des fois il ya des
couples des familles qui partent en
vacances si on voit que le lien n'est
pas l'un on le sent en tant que
photographe
tout ça pour dire que finalement au delà
de la carte postale
les vacances c'est peut-être aussi une
fuite
pour certains dont la vie ne leur
plaisent pas c'est une façon pendant une
semaine d'oublier ce quotidien qui nous
plaît pas on économise pour oublier donc
cela avec un peu plus de recul on peut
se dire que certaines personnes qui on
va dire une vie qui leur plaisent vont
s'accorder des vacances pour avoir un
petit répit mais pareil en coupe
téléphone on oublie son quotidien
il ya quand même le retour à la réalité
après enfin on approche de chefs
d'entreprise m'a fait non pas regarder
ni observé mais essayez d'analyser le
vacancier qui vient ici en martinique
c'est un client il a payé pour faire ses
vacances donc s'il a payé quelque chose
c'est que pour après ça lui apporte
quelque chose
et ma question alors été quelle est la
valeur ajoutée des vacances alors vous
allez me dire on peut ramener des belles
images et souvenirs à raconter revient
peut-être plus bronzé avec des cadeaux
dans la valise mais souvent il ya aussi
on regarde son relevé sur internet me
l'euro 2000 je sais pas de sou en moins
et des fois on est même fatigué des
vacances et faut se reposer des vacances
voyez un petit peu donc je me suis dis
finalement les vacances c'est un
investissement puisque on paye pour ça
quand tu essaies vacances puisque on
économise pour ce à quoi des ces
vacances qui deviennent maintenant un
luxe et de ce constat a émergé l'idée de
concept de vacances revis revit sa part
d'une question et si les vacances
c'était l'occasion de changer et si le
fait de rentrer de vacances ce soit un
plaisir
et si le rêve
ce n'était pas les vacances une petite
semaine de l'année pour les plus
chanceux et donc si le rêve ne t'ai pas
ses vacances mais sa vie qu'on ait la
vie de ses rêves
alors vos vies sa part de d'un constat
ce climat d'ainsi actifs actions général
donc au niveau du travail relationnel
malaise au niveau corporel pas bien dans
la tête nous donne envie d'aller encore
plus en vacances
tellement quand on rentre de vacances on
se confronte à la réalité
donc on a hâte de retourner en vacances
et donc ses vacances de rêve irréel
c'est comme une fuite
le constat aujourd'hui c'est que le
marché des vacances n'est plus comme il
était avant au niveau on a vu en
martinique au niveau de l'hôtellerie les
touristes fuient les hôtels et s'oriente
vers d'autres types d'hébergement
au niveau national et international les
clubs de vacances ferment leur porte un
nom plus autant d'attraits par rapport à
peut-être un besoin de renouvellement et
à côté de ça il ya un autre marché qui
est en pleine émergence
le marché du bien-être et le marché du
coaching de plus en plus de personnes se
mettent à coacher et d accompagner des
personnes et donc revis part de ce
principe de se dire que les vacances
c'est l'occasion peut-être de changer
que dans les clubs de vacances vous
voyez où il ya un animateur qui va dire
oui monsieur là avec votre éventail là
venez venez chanter allez allez sur des
petites chansons et bien que ce type d'
animateur soi pourquoi pas des coachs
que quand vous partez en vacances vous
en profitez pour apprendre à vous
dépasser avoir confiance en vous par
exemple le changement ne peut pas être
radical mais les vacances ça peut être
l'occasion d'entrer dans une dynamique
de changement au niveau mental au niveau
corporel au niveau de l'hygiène de vie
et bien sûr au niveau de l'image images
qui partout de nos jours pourquoi ne pas
profiter des vacances pour donc
travailler sa confiance comme on a parlé
faire du sport nous l'avons par exemple
en martinique des plages de sable noir
on peut faire une belle marche se
baigner dans la mer une thalasso naturel
faire un gommage au sable noir allaient
à la rivière ensuite près revitalisant
après le sport au niveau d'hygiène
alimentaire nous avons des fruits à
faire découvrir aux touristes mais aussi
des épices vous savez le mendiant pas
dire le curcumin cet antioxydant naturel
c'est une richesse ici on peut
l'intégrer dans des soucis revitalisant
et proposer ça bien sûr aux touristes
ils découvrent des saveurs des épices et
se fait du bien la martinique c'est
aussi l'îlot pleure donc bien sûr au
delà de réapprendre la saveur des
aliments des nouveaux ces nouvelles
épices apprendre à sentir et avoir aussi
d'autres choses d'autres couleurs peu de
saveur au niveau des pratiques d'hygiène
de vie
pourquoi ne peut pas proposer aux
touristes
plutôt que d'aller faire une heure de
jet-ski de l'emmener à la rivière pour
méditer d'une part ils découvrent un
site magnifique la martinique et d'îlots
bellefleur mais il ya aussi des
magnifiques cascades
il ya aussi des belles des belles plages
donc d'une part ils découvrent un site
magnifique et d'autre part il apprend
une pratique qui par la suite peut
l'aider dans son quotidien
le travail sur l'image peut se faire
aussi pendant les vacances faire un
relooking est là qu en la personne de
rentrer de vacances
il ya quelque chose et c'est pas le
bronzage revit c'est aussi se dire mais
on nous vend du rêve les vacances la
carte postale mais on ne monte pas la
personne où elle rentre la personne qui
est dans la carte postale quand elle
rentre à son travail et si on montrait
la personne qui rentrait contente de
rentrer ce soit un plaisir de rentrer on
pourrait montrer par exemple quelqu'un
sur son lieu de travail en train de dire
écoutez là je travaille
par contre tu as voit que je rentre de
vacances
revis c'est un concept qui pourrait se
trouver dans les clubs de vacances dans
un camping pourquoi pas et mon grand
rêve à moi j'aimerais faire partager
avec vous partager avec vous aujourd'hui
ce serait qu'ils aient des croisiers 1re
vie à ce type de croisière ou
on revient avec toujours plus mais des
croisières on revient mieux passer du
quantitatif au qualitatif alors une
croisière est une croisière la
traditionnelle photo avec le capitaine
peut se faire à l'arrivée et au départ
avant après les croisières tu es allé à
la rencontre des autres cultures et bien
sûr une croisière vie
c'est aller à la rencontre des autres
cultures mais pourquoi pas aller à la
rencontre des autres si on est à bord
d'un bateau c'est qu'il ya d'autres
personnes à connaître apprendre à
communiquer c'est aussi aller à la
rencontre de ses proches ils font part
en famille les enfants sont d'un côté
les parents de l'autre côté on part en
coûte
madame ni son lieu monsieur fait le
sport donc allé à la rencontre de ses
proches c'est en profiter pour aller à
la rencontre de soi si on part et pour
prendre un peu de recul pour revenir
différents alors pourquoi revit revisser
la racine du mot français revivant parce
que tous on est quelque part sur terre
un moment donné mais n'importe quoi on
peut revivre à partir du moment où on
prend conscience de certaines choses et
qu'on agit en conséquence
revivre c'est aussi la racine du mot
anglais revised comme ravivées alors
pour ceux qui connaissent les feux de
cheminée en métropole et qui ont déjà vu
un feu quasiment éteint avec un peu de
braise ou pour ceux qui ont essayé de
faire griller un peu de poulet à pâques
sur un barbecue dit qu'il le ferait du
mal à apprendre
vous savez quoi ya très peu juste un
petit peu de brèves
qu'est ce qu'il faut pour refaire
démarrer le feu bien écouter juste une
petite brindille de quoi juste une
brindille et c'est reparti et bien
finalement les vacances et cette
brindille ma grande idée pour ma petite
île ne serait que de martinique on
puisse partir en croisière et dans une
croisière spéciale où on part à la
découverte des autres cultures de la
caraïbe par exemple et on en reviens
différent avec quelque chose qui fait
que notre famille nos proches nos amis
le collègue de travail nous disent en
rentrant mais il ya quelque chose a
changé et quelque chose
alors messieurs dames
pour répondre à la devinette de tout à
l'heure eh bien écoutez je rentre de
vacances et j'ai hâte de rentrer merci
pour votre écoute
là